yeah welcome to this video a video that
is looking at at different compared to
the other ones camera is a bit different
I'm in a studio actually not an add my
own and I'm in Hamburg Germany at the
offices of chess to any form I've in the
process of recording a video series
almost finished on the Rue Lopez a
couple of hours of content giving an
overview of this great opening to be
released in short order one or two weeks
probably in the chest to any form
premium membership area mmpi check that
out the other thing that this video is
for is telling you that tomorrow on
march twenty seventh at at five central
european time i´m going to do a bend to
Blitzer just what i usually do you have
me on camera though and i'm going to
play on the chest 24 hour plays own yeah
this will be five central europe in time
which makes it nunam at the east coast
at the moment of the five our time
different system to the US yeah i hope
you are going to join me tomorrow and
watch me live the link is in the
description to the video it's a little
bit different than usual but you see the
link in the description just click there
at five on do interview on the east
coast tomorrow thanks a lot